when Tesla introduces a new car the
world goes crazy with excitement is one
of the most hotly anticipated tech and
automotive products and this is it kind
of underwhelming looks exactly the same
as the old car because it is everything
that's new is inside on a software
update got a notification saying and
update is ready I accepted it it took
about 45 minutes and then the whole of
the inside of my car is like an entirely
new vehicle and this will apply to any
Tesla on the rover and Model S or X this
car is now running version 8.0 it's
Tesla's latest software this is a beta
version that we've been given an early
look at it's on this 17 inch screen here
in the center this is the way you
interact with your Tesla and this is
where you see all the differences first
thing I notice is that everything looks
a bit more modern and a bit flatter the
music interface is much nicer his local
radio his streaming radio or you can
listen to your own phone still not very
many controls for your own phone maps
appear aware things look really nice I
can navigate and one touch I'm just
going to go to the wired office which is
not very far away from here proceed to
the highlighted road onto 9th Street and
the Tesla has now made it so these icons
at the top will actually go away so the
map will take up the entire screen area
and really give you this a huge view
which is useful when you're navigating
there is a downside to that and that
these buttons are then hidden and
slightly harder to get to you have to
tap the screen twice in order to pull
down the menu bar and then tap on
whatever else you want voice recognition
has been improved with an accident
that's something that I definitely
appreciate now you just tap the button
and then up here I can say navigate to
the nearest Starbucks and it will write
on the screen what it thinks I said it
got it and then on the maps over on the
center screen it brings up a list of all
the Starbucks of the nearby
one of those functional improvements is
for the driver display when I activate
autopilot it now shows me the speed it's
set to very clearly and a bright blue
circle show auto steering is on the car
is keeping itself in its lane and that
is an improvement that a lot of people
have been asking for it makes it much
clearer when the system is and isn't
active and one of the best things about
getting a whole new interface well at
least it gives you something to look at
and play with while you're sitting in
bumper-to-bumper traffic